Heat.
[Music]
[Applause]
Heat. Heat. Heat.
[Music]
[Applause]
Hello and welcome to another episode of
WhatsApp Prof. Hello Walter.
>> You beat me this time.
>> I had to. I've been losing out the whole
time.
>> No. Hello, Martin.
>> Are you doing well?
>> I'm trying.
>> Yeah, that's the only thing the Bible
says. It doesn't matter how many times
you fall.
>> Who said I fell?
>> I'm old. All I do is stumble these days.
>> Okay.
>> Now, let's stumble through this
presentation. and let's stumble through
it.
>> But we'll ask the Lord to be a cane or
something just to help us through it.
>> Yes,
>> a walking stick.
>> Let's pray. Our heavenly father,
we are living in momentous times and
things are happening around us and our
eyes can easily be deceived. So we ask
that you help us to make some sense of
the things out there and help us to
bring this also to people out there. We
ask this in Jesus name. Amen.
>> Amen.
Martin, there are two questions which we
want to address today. The talk is
really about the king of the south
today.
>> Yeah. Like uh our backdrop is uh about
um people there's not a lot of people
that wants to say that or want to agree
with us.
>> No.
>> About who the king of the north and
south is. Well, I think there are some
voices that are speaking sanity at the
moment which we will refer to on this
issue.
But uh just briefly before we get to the
issue of the king of the south which
this presentation is about
there's one thing that uh is
uh a thorn
>> that constantly is being pressed into
our side.
Namely, can we overcome sin? We've had
so many people write to us that we claim
that we can't overcome sin.
>> And of course, this is a gross
distortion of what we are saying because
there are people out there that just
love to distort what anyone says, right?
>> Mhm.
>> And to those distorters, we would like
to just clearly say what the situation
is.
And with that, we're going to close the
subject.
>> Yeah.
>> Because to continue to speak about it
because no matter what you say, these
people will distort it and make you say
what you didn't say. Although they think
you did say it because they want to
think that you said it when you never
said it. Let's put it that way.
>> It's exactly what you just said.
I listened to one of them and he said,
"Walter Feith is saying this, but he
meant this."
>> That was an excellent one. Yes, he's
saying this, but obviously he's not
saying that. He's saying something else.
>> So, all right. I don't want to get into
adjectives for these people, even though
they they are a thorn. And a thorn is
well, let's put it bluntly. Very
irritating.
Okay. So, can we overcome sin? Let's
just deal with that briefly. We're not
going to go into it in in any great.
>> We've done that already. So,
>> it's been done so many times and people
don't listen.
>> So, can we overcome sin? Question.
What we have said consistently is that
we have a sinful nature.
And this nature will remain with us
until Christ comes and changes our vile
body unto his glorious body. And we have
no righteousness to lay claim to other
than the righteousness of Christ. If
they want to say according to what is
written over there that we say you
cannot stop sinning, well then I can't
help them. then obviously there is a
brain dysfunction somewhere.
>> So let's just go to the Bible and sort
this out and to the spirit of prophecy.
Romans 3:10. We could put 100 verses
there, but just one. That's it.
>> As it is written, there is none
righteous. No, not one. It doesn't say
there there's no one righteous until
they've become perfect and become
sinless. It doesn't say that.
>> No, not even the last generation.
>> No, there is none righteous. No, not
one. So, I'm very sorry for you, Martin,
but you are not righteous.
>> You can be clothed with the
righteousness of Christ.
>> Yes. And then
>> but if you think that you are righteous,
then you are sitting with your own
garment.
All right, let's get this quote again.
We've shown it a hundred times, but
let's just show it again. We cannot say
I am sinless
till this vile body is changed and
fashioned like unto his glorious body.
Martin, you don't dazzle my eyes.
>> No, I'm sorry.
>> You definitely don't have a glorified
body.
>> No. And I think I don't have one either.
But if we constantly seek to follow
Jesus, the blessed hope is ours of
standing before the throne of God
without spot or wrinkle or any such
thing, complete in Christ, robed in his
righteousness and perfection. Is this in
harmony with Romans 3:10?
>> It's exactly the same. The the Romans
just didn't include the last portion of
his righteousness and perfection yet.
>> Yes. All right. So, does this mean that
we are doomed to continue sinning
because we have a sinful nature?
>> No.
>> Now, it's a problem.
>> But these people say that we say yes,
you will continue sinning.
>> No, they just don't understand what
we're saying. No, they don't want to
understand
>> because they want to be perfect
>> and they want to call themselves
righteous.
>> Yes.
So what we are actually saying Martin is
that we have a sinful propensity.
And that it will remain with us until
Christ comes. But that does not mean
that we must act out our propensity.
>> Yeah.
Christ died for us and when he we accept
his atoning sacrifice, repent and are
reborn in him, he covers us with his
righteousness
and by his spirit removes our hearts of
stone and brings us into harmony with
his will.
Sin becomes abhorren to us and we see it
for what it is. If we say that we cannot
overcome sin, then we are saying that
Christ cannot work in us and that would
be a denial of the gospel.
Is that fair enough?
>> Definitely.
>> But I have a propensity.
>> Mhm. Just explain the one of the alcoh
alcoholic.
>> Yes. If you're an alcoholic, you're an
alcoholic. You have a propensity
for alcohol drinking.
>> That doesn't mean you have to give into
it. You don't have to go to the bar, but
you remain an alcoholic because once you
take that first sip, you're you're
cooked again. Right.
So, Martin, we have a sinful propensity.
And for those that think that they are
perfect, I suggest they drop a 20 lb
hammer onto their toe and see how
perfect their disposition is. Especially
if it's done a few times off repeatedly.
>> It's like that joke of the of the
electrician pouring molten lead into one
of those capacitors.
>> Mhm.
>> And he he misses the mark and it falls
down the back of his of his companion
working below. And that one is arrested
for public profanity.
And the judge asks him, "What did you
say?" He said, "Charles,
please take care with that molten lead
when next time you pour it. It went
right down my back, and I would
appreciate it if you would take a little
bit more care." Yeah. The judge, would
he have believed him?
>> I don't believe him either.
>> You don't believe You don't believe him?
Anyway,
>> well,
>> let's let's continue with this story.
All right. When the conflict is ended,
this comes from the sons of times.
When the times of refreshing shall come
from the presence of the Lord, then the
sins of the repentant soul who has
received the grace of Christ and has
overcome through the blood of the lamb
will be removed from the records of
heaven
and will be placed upon Satan, the
scapegoat, the originator of sin, and be
remembered no more against him forever.
When the conflict of life is ended, when
the armor is laid off at the feet of
Jesus, when the saints of God are
glorified. So two here, when you die or
when you are glorified, that's at the
second coming of Christ. Then and then
only will it be safe to claim that we
are saved and sinless.
Now there are people that will say oh so
you have no security in terms of your
salvation.
>> You see whenever you do a simple
statement just to try to then the other
side comes and throws it all out again
this side. So they will say oh so you
are saying when you never said you just
read a quote that's all you did
>> it's for instance I was just thinking
when we were you were telling the joke
and we were laughing then we will have
people now say oh so you're making a
mockery of Jesus's atoning that he had
to die for your sin
>> they can do whatever they like the fact
of the matter is we have a sinful nature
we have a sinful propensity
but we don't want to sin and we abhore
sin
>> that is the situation until we die or
until we receive a glorified body.
>> One of the two.
>> Through doing that, you're glorifying
Christ again. That's the main thing. We
never want to say get it. You put it
never on yourself.
>> Okay. So, they will say, "Oh, so you you
say that you can't say I'm saved."
What you can say is I have faith in him
who started a good work in me that he
will bring it to completion. Then the
onus is not on me but on him.
>> So take take away this ego trip and rely
upon Christ.
>> Let him
>> uh declare us righteous and let him
declare you
>> saved.
>> Now let's have a look at what the Bible
says. All right. Less people say, "Okay,
you're only quoting the spirit of
prophecy."
I looked up the words sin not in that
sequence in the Bible. There are plenty
of others. You can get hundreds and
hundreds of texts regarding sin and what
it does. But the words sin not in the
King James. And it spat out 10 verses.
The first one is in Exodus 20:20. And
Moses said unto the people, "Fear not,
for God is come to prove you, and that
his fear may be before your faces, that
ye sin not."
So, does he want you to sin?
>> No.
>> No. Doesn't want you to sin. But, uh, if
you have God in mind and you reverence
him, it'll help you to sin not.
>> Is that what the text means?
>> Exactly. It is appropriating his help
because you're keeping your face on him.
>> All right. So, who's doing this in you?
>> Him.
>> Okay. This is now the Old Testament.
>> Of course, in the New Testament, the law
is gone. So, you can sin, right?
>> That's the other ex in case people say
that I'm saying that now. I'm being
facitious. Right?
>> 1st Samuel 14:34. Saul said, "Disperse
yourselves among the people and say unto
them, bring me hither every man his ox
and every man his sheep and slay them
here and eat and sin not against the
Lord in eating with the blood." So he
doesn't want you to sin. He wants you to
practice things that are not sinful.
>> Psalms 4:4, "Stand in awe and sin not.
Commune with your own heart upon your
bed and be still.
Be still and know that I am God. Right?
>> And to be with your own heart is to make
it right with God.
>> Ah Psalms 39 verse1 to the chief
musician
a psalm of David. I said I will take
heed to my ways that I sin not with my
tongue.
Take heed
>> and sin not. I will keep my mouth with a
bridal while the wicked is before me.
>> Wow that's a very strong one. So he even
keeps your his mouth while he's agitated
with the
>> Yes.
>> He's the wicked.
>> Who's he battling against here? His
sinful nature. Right.
>> That's it.
>> All right. Nevertheless, says Ezekiel,
if they warn the righteous man, or God
says through Ezekiel
that the righteous sin not and he does
not sin, he shall live. Is there a
condition there?
>> Yeah. Because and you bring it back to
transgression of the law is death.
>> Yes. Because he warned also that thou
hast delivered thy soul.
>> So let's jump to the New Testament.
Awake to righteousness
and sin not.
Who is righteousness? Martin Christ.
For some have not knowledge of God. I
speak this to your shame.
Ephesians, be angry
and sin not. It's a tough one.
>> That's amazing.
>> It's a tough one.
And let not the sun go down upon your
wroth.
So, can you be wrothful sometimes until
the sun goes down? So, you have to
really work at yourself and say, "I
don't want to do this. I don't want to
do this." Yeah.
>> And so not
>> and and what if that molten lead does go
down your your back?
>> You'll have to go back to Christ.
>> Okay.
one John. My little children, these
things write down unto you that you s
not.
But if the molten lead falls down your
back and you blow a gasket,
we have an advocate with the father,
Jesus Christ the righteous.
I don't know, am I allowed to paraphrase
that verse like that?
>> Maybe,
>> maybe. But
>> I'll still get into trouble if I do it
that way. Right.
>> If any man sees brother sin, a sin which
is not unto death, he shall ask and he
shall give him life for them that sin
not unto death. There's a sin unto
death. I do not say that he shall pray
for it. That's a sin against the Holy
Spirit. When you sin unto death,
uh we must help each other. We must
support each other.
All unrighteousness is sin and there is
a sin not
unto death. Well, I was just thinking
when we were reading the portion where
it said and if eminent man sin, we have
an advocate with the father. Now,
there's the view that last day theology
has that when we stand without a
mediator, this is where the problem
comes in. So, you have
>> then you will have already reached
perfection. No, because you have still
an unglorified body.
So, how will you stand without an
mediator? Well, the Bible tells us what
will happen. He says he will give his
angels charge over you and they will
protect you from this onslaught. In
other words, they will keep the evil
angels influence away from you. You have
been settled in the truth. You know what
is truth. You're not going to give up
the truth. and the angels will protect
you in that time until he comes.
The idea that something special will be
done to the last generation
is is erroneous in my opinion because
the way in which you are saved
throughout all generations has never
ever changed. There will be no change at
the end. So when Elijah was translated
and taken up to heaven, was he a special
case that received this special blessing
or was he like Mary according to the
Catholic faith that got an immaculate
conception so that she had an unfallen
nature?
>> Cannot.
>> So none of that applies. None of that
applies. The plan of salvation is the
same all the way through. And when Jesus
comes, he will change this vile body
into his glorious body. But while you
are standing there without a m mediator,
it is the angels that protect you from
evil influences.
And his holy spirit that has worked with
you and with your mind keeps you in your
thinking pattern that you have
established so that you cannot be moved.
Yeah,
>> that's what it means to be so settled in
the truth that you cannot be moved.
That's what it means to be sealed.
>> So, can I say in straight terms that in
that time you probably won't sin?
>> No, you probably won't sin. In fact, you
won't sin.
>> You won't sin. You will not sin in that
time. That does not mean that you're
sinless yet because Jesus will is going
to
>> I cannot say that I'm sinless. but you
won't sin in that time. And I think
that's clearing out a big confusion
about how people think.
>> Yes. So basically, we're saying the same
thing. We're just not going that step
further and being glorified to the point
of being sinless because Martin,
>> are the angels
sinless?
>> Yes.
>> Are they without a propensity to sin?
>> Yes, they are without a propensity to
sin. Uh did they fall?
>> Yes. A third of them sinned.
>> Okay. Let's take another example. Adam
in Eden.
>> Mhm.
>> Was he sinless?
>> Yes.
>> Was he without a propensity to sin?
>> Did he fall?
>> Yes.
>> Therefore, could he fall?
>> That makes a big difference.
>> It makes a big difference. So, Martin,
even if you could in the end stand
without a mediator in your own
perfection, you would still fall without
Christ.
>> 100%. Will we be able to still sin when
we get to heaven eventually,
>> Martin? If Christ died for your freedom
of choice, is going to take it away?
>> No.
>> That would be ridiculous. All that
effort, why didn't he take it away in
the first place and solve the problem
then? Right.
>> Exactly. So, you will still be able to
sin.
>> Will you sin?
>> No.
>> You will be because you've you've
settled into the truth that you cannot
be moved.
>> Okay. And who is the truth?
>> Christ.
>> Ah. So, not even an angel is safe
without Christ. If Christ did not die
for this for sin, eventually
all of them would have fallen.
>> Angels, fallen, unfallen worlds,
everybody would probably eventually sin.
>> So everybody in heaven will still be
dependent upon Christ
in order to remain for all eternity
sinless.
But there will be no one casting doubt
>> upon Christ anymore. It is the seed of
doubt that was cast upon Christ which
led to a separation from Christ which
automatically led to sin. Yeah, that's
what happened. So if there are 10 verses
in the Bible that say sin not,
is God asking the impossible then?
>> No. No.
All right. So, the third angel's message
is righteousness by faith in verity.
Several have written to me inquiring if
the message of justification by faith is
the third angel's message. And I have
answered it is the third angel's message
in verity. It is in truth the message.
But it says do not break God's
commandments and do not keep a false set
of commandments and do not take the mark
of the beast which is a self-righteous
commandment not found in the Bible.
Right?
>> It is.
>> Then how is it righteousness by faith?
Because you can't do it without the
righteousness of Christ that covers you
and his empowerment which enables you.
Yeah.
So it presents an uplifted savior.
That's what it does. This message was to
bring more prominently before the world
the uplifted savior, the sacrifice for
sins of the whole world. It presented
justification through faith in shity. It
invites the people to receive the
righteousness of Christ which is made
manifest in obedience to all the
commandments of God. There's the crux of
the matter.
If you receive the righteousness, you
are enabled to keep the commandments
and therefore it is made manifest.
>> Yeah.
>> Martin, were you a Sabbath breaker
before you discovered the righteousness
of Christ?
>> Yes, of course.
>> All right. Yes, of course. Now that you
have discovered the righteousness of
Christ, did you give up the false
Sabbath and keep the true Sabbath of the
Bible?
>> Yes.
>> It was easy, right?
>> But you did it.
>> Yes.
>> Why?
>> Because it's the truth. And I believe
that that's what God requires of us.
>> Oh. And then you did it.
>> Yeah.
>> So you stopped that sin.
>> Yes. They needed to have their eyes
directed to his divine person, his
merits, his changeless love for the
human family. All power is given into
his hands that he may dispense rich
gifts unto men, imparting the priceless
gift
of his own righteousness to the helpless
human agent. This is the message that
God commanded to be given to the world.
It is the third angel's message which is
to be proclaimed with a loud voice and
attend it with the outpouring of his
spirit in a large measure. So Martin all
we are saying is stop boasting about
your sinlessness and accept the
righteousness of Christ as your ticket
your title to heaven. Never say huh look
at me.
>> Yeah
>> it is phariseaical. It's there's there's
a verse that says take heed lest you
think you stand and you fall. That's
pertaining to when you think now I've
attained.
>> All right. So let's ask the question
again. Can we overcome sin?
We have to overcome sin
and can overcome sin in him.
Martin, if you don't put the in him
there,
you're barking up the wrong tree.
>> And you know what? Be careful because
sometimes they put in him there, but
it's just lip service
>> because they say they will stand without
a mediator and therefore be perfect. Not
even angel can stand without Christ and
be perfect.
He enable us. He directs us. He lives
out his life within us.
Then I asked the question, yeah, Martin,
don't we sing that?
>> Live out thy life within me,
>> oh Jesus, etc., etc., etc. Don't we sing
it?
>> Yeah.
>> Lest we should boast and say we are
sinless. We need a humble approach to
our abilities. Instead of boasting about
our achievements and saying that we are
sinless, let us remember who we are and
give glory to God for such a great
salvation. The character that we develop
here is the character that we take with
us to heaven. Would you agree with that
statement?
>> I love that statement.
>> So, let's see what Christ Objects
Lessons has to say. When the voice of
God awakes the dead,
he will come from the grave with the
same appetites and passions,
the same likes and dislikes that he
cherished when living.
God works. No miracle to recreate a man
who would not be recreated when he was
granted every opportunity and provided
with every facility.
During his lifetime, he took no delight
in God nor found pleasure in his
servants. His character is not in
harmony with God. And he could not be
happy in the heavenly family.
Simple.
the thoughts that you take with you to
your grave or the thoughts that you wake
up with. Your rebellion that you take
with you to the grave is the same
rebellion that you wake up to.
>> Yeah. Yeah. God,
>> the only one who can take that away is
Christ.
>> Yeah. He's not going to change your
character while you're in the grave.
>> So, is there some overcoming to be done
here?
>> Yes.
>> By the deeds of the law shall no flesh
be justified. There's no power in the
law to save the transgressor of the law.
If man after his transgression could
have been saved by his utmost energy to
keep the law,
then Jesus need not have died. Didn't
the Pharisees wash the cup on the inside
and the outside and strain everything
they drank so they wouldn't drink an
unclean net?
Did it help them?
>> No.
>> The man could have stood in his own
merit and said, "I am sinless." Isn't
that what these people are saying?
>> It's that robe that you turn up with at
the wedding feast and the and he says,
"Friend,
whose garment do you have on?" Okay,
sorry that we we slipped up there. We'll
be perfect now. You don't have to die.
No problem. God will never bring down
the law to man's standard. And man can
never lift himself up to answer to its
claims of perfection.
But Christ comes to our world and pays
the sinner's debt, suffers the penalty
for transgression of the law, and
satisfies justice. Now the sinner may
claim the righteousness of Christ. Where
sin abounded, grace did much more
abound.
The sinner may now claim the
righteousness of
>> of Christ. Not look at me, I'm the bee's
knees now. Romans 5:8. But God
commendeth his love towards us that
while we were yet sinners, Christ died
for us.
It's pretty plain to me.
>> Yeah. So, let's mull it over again.
Would you say thus potentially
every single person can be saved because
of the blood of Christ that is
sufficient for all?
>> Yes.
Does this mean that all will be saved?
>> No.
No.
Because only those that accept the plan
of salvation and fulfill the conditions
will be saved. Is that right?
>> Potentially every man can have access to
heaven, but few there are that find it
because they do not seek. Would you
agree with that?
>> Yes.
>> But what about those that have never
heard of the truth? And is there a
difference between those that know the
truth and those that don't?
>> Definitely.
>> Isn't that a good question? Well, you
can read Romans. It has a lot to say
about those that are under the law and
those that are not under the law. In
other words, those that know the law,
know God's way, and those that don't
know the way. But one little quote here.
Oh, but you just opened the can of worms
now. So, you're going to have to do
something about Romans because that is
what exactly what you've just mentioned
is one reason why probably the whole
evangelical world says that that you
don't have to keep the law anymore.
>> Do we make void there by the law? God
forbid we above the law.
>> That's a balancing one.
>> Okay. They always leave that verse out.
>> All right. So, let's see what uh
manuscripts 130 says. A comment on John
15:22.
God's tests differ. Morton,
that's what Romans also said. By the
way, God's test of the heathen who have
not the light and of those living with
the knowledge of truth and light has
been abundant is alltogether different.
He accepts from those in heathen lands a
phase of righteousness which does not
satisfy him when offered by those of
Christian lands.
He does not require much where much has
not been bestowed.
What? And this is such a bummer of a
statement. It's absolutely in harmony
with Romans.
>> Yeah.
So Martin, if you've accepted Christ and
you say you are a Christian,
>> does that place more responsibility upon
you?
>> Definitely.
>> So does that mean that in Christ you
have to strive to overcome to in order
to be an example to others?
>> For sure. Then you're growing
has to um be excelled.
>> Yes. So in harmony with the spirit of
prophecy, I would like to publicly state
that I have never claimed to be sinless.
I've never claimed to have overcome
completely and utterly my sinful nature.
But I have certainly claimed that I do
not want to sin.
>> Absolutely.
>> And by the grace of Christ, I can
overcome sin. Otherwise, what would be
the point of sanctification? Yeah,
>> there would be no sanctification. Then
we can dispense with it and we can just
sit with justification and carry on
sinning
>> and then we can throw away the law.
>> Yes. So anyone who wants to say that we
claim that you will have to continue
sinning because you have a sinful
nature, they don't understand
righteousness by faith. Neither do they
understand sanctification.
Because by the way the Bible also says
without sanctification no one will see
God.
>> But the measure
of how much you understand on the issue
plays a role because God is a fair God.
>> I think people misunderstand
sanctification. They think you have to
work work towards sanctification but
it's Christ that sanctifies you.
>> It's not by works of the law that you
are saved. It is only works that are
done by Christ in you
>> that have any value with God.
>> It actually keeps you in the
sanctification.
>> So even a heathen
that is decent and kind is actuated by
the spirit of Christ even though he
doesn't know it. Because by himself he
would be
like any other tyrant
>> because his boss would be the tyrant of
tyrants.
>> Yeah.
>> Namely Satan.
>> I hope that puts the matter to rest. I
don't want to talk about it again.
But uh Martin, I cannot wait to have a
glorified body. So that this constant
struggle against self, having to wake up
with a baseball bat to batter the old
man of sin to death every morning
>> can finally come to an end.
>> I agree.
>> I've kept the ways of the Lord and have
not wickedly departed from my God.
That's David speaking.
Martin, you read the story of David and
look what he says over here. Of course,
this is the type of Christ
that really did this. He's not done
anything wickedly or ever departed from
him. So, his only claim would be the
type of Christ.
For all his judgments were before me,
and I did not put away his statutes from
me. I was always upright before him, and
I kept myself from my iniquity.
Does that rhyme with the sto story of
David in the Bible?
>> No.
>> No. But it does rhyme with the antitype.
>> That's it. With Christ.
>> So, let's put the emphasis where it is.
And now, let's start our discussion for
today.
>> Yes.
having dispensed with that one hopefully
once and for all.
We're talking about the king of the
north and the king of the south.
And our last one was again about the
Middle East and about the king of the
north. Who is he? Is he the papacy or is
it Turkey or is it Islam or who is it?
And we came out very firmly that the
Bible is very clear that the king of the
north is the one that uh rules and
swings the scepter at the end of the
time.
>> And it is the little horn power.
And if you read in Daniel, you will say
see that a judgment is taking place in
heaven.
>> Mhm. while the little horn is speaking
pompous words down here.
>> That's what it is about, right?
>> Nobody can deny that the the little horn
is the papacy
>> and therefore nobody can really deny
that he is the king of the north.
>> No. And like you me we showed in that um
episode the mystery Babylon and all of
that can only be one that Babylon king
of the north,
>> right? But um a lot of people if they
want to see some deeper studies that
we've did that because a lot of people
asked for it. You did it in rekindling
the reformation. We'll put the links in
the description of this video
>> for who the king of the north is. We
you've never changed your position.
>> Never.
>> We did episode 204 that clearly did a
whole study on Daniel 11.
>> Yes.
>> They can watch that. But then Matthew
Sanche
recently did also a excellent
video.
>> Yes. And he was associated with the very
people that are now claiming that Turkey
is the king of the north and therefore
Islam will play the major role at the
end. And uh he has distanced himself
from that teaching and separated from
that mindset. So I'll put a link to that
>> link because he did an excellent job and
uh we don't have to repeat what he said
because he did he did a very good job.
So look at what he says.
>> What was interesting is I just remember
now in total onslaught you did Islamic
connection.
>> Yes.
>> Now that will be difficult to find some
places. So we'll put a link to where you
can find it as well because some places
have taken it off. They've taken it off
because they erroneously believe that
Turkey is the king of the north. Yes.
>> And others of course believe that Islam
is the king of the south.
>> So we're going to deal with that portion
now. But
>> that person and then we're going to no
longer focus on that because we have end
time events to watch and cannot uh you
know constantly put out these fires that
are burning all over uh the internet.
What we can do is we just show in the
future how the here's the king of the
north fitting in with the king of the
south. How that fits in the old don't
have to go back to the whole Bible study
and do the Bible study every time.
That's why we've done it already. But
for sake of completeness, the king of
the south, let's do it.
>> So let's just briefly again look at this
statement that uh was the issue of the
time. Uriah Smith's idea. And remember
that in the time of Uriah Smith, the
fall of the Ottoman p empire, in fact
just slightly before that uh Lich for
example, he and the Millerite movement
uh were prophesying what was written in
Daniel
and came to the conclusion that the
Ottoman Empire which was centered
basically in Turkey would fall. Mhm.
>> And it did.
>> Yeah. They actually predicted the exact
date everything
>> and this was an important
uh milestone
in giving empetus to the prophetic
outline.
>> Yeah.
>> But it was a historic event that has
taken place.
>> Yes.
>> Now to take that historic event and
expand it to the end of the time. If
that were the case, then the spirit of
prophecy and the great controversy in
particular would have emphasized that
that is the way in which it's going to
deal. Not a word.
>> In fact, it is the beast out of the sea
and the beast out of the earth that are
the
emphasis in that study. So just to go
back to the history to show what
happened. There
is the ideas that Uriah Smith had and
James White had and later the
pioneers in general
all had this concept that James White
had. Just because Ellen White endorsed
Daniel and Revelation of Uriah Smith
because it had much truth in it and
because it also emphasized that this
Ottoman power would fall and it was
fulfilled to the day. Uh therefore there
was a lot of truth in it but expanding
it all the way to the end was never
endorsed by her in any shape or form.
and not one of the books that she wrote
nothing
>> up until 1915
you can read the testimony to the to the
church correct every volume it's just
papacy
>> and by the way Martin if we study the
book of revelation which takes us all
the way through the end nowhere in there
other than the parts in in the historic
arm uh ever referred to Islam so
historically yes but then when When it
comes to esquetology, what's going to
happen at the end of time? So,
Revelation chapter 10, 11, 12, 13, 14,
15, all the way to the end of the book
tell us what's going to happen. And the
role players are the beast out of the
sea, the beast out of the earth. And
never any more mention of any other
power such as Islam. Never.
So, let's have a look at this issue.
One of the testimonies to individuals
delivered most likely only in oral form
was addressed to James White.
A reproof for his course of action just
before the combined camp meeting and
general conference session. He and Uriah
Smith held conflicting views on the
prophecy of the king of the north
pictured in Daniel 11 and the power
presented in verse 45 that would come to
his end with none to help him. White in
his Sabbath morning address September 28
in the newly pitched camp meeting tent
countered Smith's interpretations.
He felt that Smith's approach indicating
that the world was on the verge of
Armageddon would threaten the strong
financial support needed for the rapidly
expanding work of the church. So this is
the written in the lonely years.
You know, I I saw somebody that argued
that I smith did this just to so not be
he countered this king of the north um
view of Iah Smith, but just to prohibit
that there was any um problems. Do you
think he would have done it just for
that? Nonsense. Absolute nonsense. So,
Ellen White's message to her husband was
a reproof for taking a course that would
lead the people to observe differences
of opinion among leaders and to lower
their confidence in them. For the church
leaders to stand in a divided position
before the people was hazardous.
James White accepted the reproof, but it
was one of the most difficult
experiences he was called to cope with,
for he felt he was doing the right
thing. Mhm.
>> He was doing the right thing
theologically.
>> The way in which he did it that was a
problem.
>> And we all have a some we have to work
on that and sometimes how we present
something instead of what we're saying.
>> And then very interestingly at no time
did Ellen White reveal which man was
right in the position he held.
That was not the issue. The crux of the
matter was the importance of leaders
presenting a united front before the
people. But as we've said, you can study
Revelation, the entire esqueological
half of the book and not find Islam or
Turkey or any one of them anywhere
mentioned whatsoever. Neither will you
find it in the great controversy.
Neither will you find it in any of the
other writings. It is always the uh
beast out of the earth, evangelical
Christianity and the beast out of the
sea, the papacy that is the pivot around
which everything revolves.
>> When you got the portion and all the
world wonder after the after the beast,
>> correct?
>> These people want to say that that will
only be after the close of probation,
but we've seen and you'll see that in
Matt in Matt Matt's presentation as
well. You've done it numerous times.
>> Numerous times.
>> We've shown now all the rel everybody is
in actually in all everybody's running
to the pope. In any case,
>> yes, I we even did one in the past or I
did one in the past on the Exodus and
the Pharaoh of the Exodus and why the
plagues fell. It had nothing to do with
Turkey attacking Jerusalem. It always
had to do with making void God's law. Ye
people, make ye Moses, make the people
Shabbat. keep the Sabbath rest. That was
the issue. Same issue will be at the
end. It is a an issue of the man of sin
versus Christ.
>> Amen.
>> So, we're going to dispense with this.
We've done one on it. The last one that
we did, Matthew just did one. Put the
link in there. Look at that. I'm sure he
will continue his good work. and don't
get confused by all these strange winds
of doctrine that are blowing out there.
So now let's just address the king of
the south because Martin there was
another one that quoted that the king of
the south is also Islam. Yeah.
>> They want to push it in everywhere.
>> So let's just do a little study and see
what the Bible has to say upon it. Now
remember the spirit of prophecy never
clearly in so many words says the king
of the north is the papacy, the king of
the south is whatever it is, right? You
have to read it from history and from
prophecy.
>> So the king of the south historically
was Egypt just like the king of the
north was Babylon.
So who or what could represent the
antityypical king of the south? That's
the question that we have. So in
Revelation 11, there's depicted a war
against God's word in which his two
witnesses, that is the Old and the New
Testament, are openly attacked by a
power from the bottomless pit.
For centuries, the church of Rome had
ruled and the word of God had been
hidden in a dead language. and under
traditions and fables.
The reformation restored the word to
humanity
and Satan deployed a new strategy to
destroy its veracity.
So the reformation that said you know
this is the criteria that we work with.
We work with the Bible and the Bible
alone. This is it. Now that destroys the
power of the papacy that bases its
things on tradition and all the other
issues. So now how do you attack the
Bible? Well, you have to sort of use
another strategy. So
>> it's well they've used a few strategies.
One was changing it a little bit here, a
little bit there.
>> That is it. Yeah. uh going in with
something like evolution and accepting
that all those
>> we have to we have to look at the whole
picture.
So when error in one go has been
detected that's what the reformation
did. This comes from the great
controversy.
Satan only masks it in a different
disguise, and multitudes receive it as
eagerly as at the first.
When the people found Romanism to be a
deception, which the Reformation
made very clear,
and he could not through this agency
lead them to transgression of God's law,
he urged them to regard all religions as
a cheat
and the Bible as a fable.
and casting aside the divine statutes,
they gave themselves up to unbridled
iniquity. So if you cast away the
directives of God, then you have
unbridled iniquity.
>> Yeah, this is lawlessness. This is ah
>> getting rid of
>> okay lawlessness.
Continue with this work. when they shall
have finished, that is their testimony,
the Old and the New Testament. The
period when the two witnesses were to
prophesy clothed in sackcloth ended in
as they were approaching the termination
of their work in obscurity, the Bible.
In other words, war was to be made upon
them by the power represented as the
beasts that ascendeth out of the
bottomless pit.
In many of the nations of Europe, the
power that ruled in church and state had
for centuries been controlled by Satan
through the medium of the papacy.
>> Not Turkey.
>> No.
>> But here is brought to view a new
manifestation of satanic power. Another
strategy.
>> Yeah.
>> The same strategist.
>> That's it. Satan using the same proxy
>> but in another form. It had been Rome's
policy under a profession of reverence
for the Bible to keep it locked up in an
unknown tongue and hidden away from the
people. Under her rule, the witnesses
prophesied clothed in sackcloth.
But another power, the beast from the
bottomless pit was to arise to make open
avowed war upon the word of God.
Okay, but it's the same master
strategist who's behind it. Satan, by
the way, who did Satan give his power
and his seat and great authority to
Rome. Revelation 13.
>> Perfect. Perfect. So, nothing has
changed.
>> We're just putting on a new disguise.
It's like a magician.
One moment he's dressed in black and the
next moment he's dressed in red.
>> Every time when Satan tried something,
he just and he saw that it was getting
to a dead end, he just moved it. But his
strategy didn't change his main plan.
>> Okay. So in Revelation, there is this
mention of the great city.
>> Mhm. In whose streets the witnesses are
slain and where their dead bodies lie as
spiritually Egypt.
>> Oh.
>> Aha. Now Martin,
who was Egypt in a literal sense
earlier?
>> King of the South.
>> Ah, but now we're talking about a
spiritual Egypt.
>> Oh, but I thought that from according to
these other guys, you cannot go from the
literal to the spiritual in in a in the
Daniel. Uhhuh. But Martin,
>> but the spirit of prophecy does it.
>> But you're allowed to do it in terms of
the entire church because the Bible
talks about spiritual Israel.
>> So Martin, spiritually Egypt,
>> would that be the equation or would that
be equated with the spiritual king of
the south?
>> Yes. Okay. Of all nations presented in
Bible history, Egypt most boldly denied
the existence of the living God.
>> So that's a criterion. Get rid of him.
>> And resisted his commands.
All right? So in other words,
lawlessness.
>> Lawlessness.
>> Do what thou wilt.
>> No monarch ever ventured upon more open
and high-handed rebellion against the
authority of heaven than did the king of
Egypt. When the message was brought to
him by Moses in the name of the Lord,
Pharaoh proudly answered, "Who is
Jehovah that I should hearken unto his
voice to let Israel go? I know not
Jehovah, and moreover, I will not let
Israel go."
This is the spirit of the spiritual
Egypt.
>> Yes. The king of the south.
>> This is atheism.
Martin. This stands in the great
controversy page 269. So atheism is
spiritually Egypt. Would you agree with
that?
>> Yes.
>> And the nations represented by Egypt
would give voice to a similar denial of
the claims of the living God and would
manifest the like spirit of unbelief and
defiance.
>> So that's making it spiritual. Put
saying that even the other ma nations
will represent the same spiritual
Yeah. Decline. Decline. So the entire
system here is spiritually Egypt. So the
great city is also compared spiritually
to Sodom.
>> Spiritually Martin
to Sodom. So now we have two things. We
have a a spirit which says atheism. Let
God not dictate what is right and wrong.
Do what thou wilt is the whole of the
law. That's the one aspect of the king
of the south.
>> And the other one is that is compared to
Sodom.
>> So the corruption of Sodom in breaking
the law of God was especially manifested
in lentiousness,
>> sexual depravity. Mhm.
And this sin was also to be a
preeeminent characteristic of the nation
that should fulfill the specifications
of the scripture.
Lentiousness. So atheism, anything that
removes God out and his law out of
society and lentiousness,
king of the south philosophy,
>> communism,
any of those.
>> Let's have a look. Let's have a look.
Can we therefore say that the spiritual
Egypt is atheism including secularism
and lentiousness?
>> Definitely.
It's clear.
>> Is it clear?
>> All right. Does it say Islam?
>> No. Nothing.
>> No.
All right. Let's have a look at a little
bit further here in the great
controversy. God's faithful witnesses
slain by the blasphemous power that
descends out of the bottomless pit were
not long to remain silent. After three
days and a half, the spirit of life from
God entered into them and they stood
upon their feet and great fear fell upon
them.
It was in 1793 that the decrees which
abolished the Christian religion and set
aside the Bible passed the French
assembly. Three years and a half later,
a resolution rescended these decrees and
thus granted toleration to the
scriptures was adopted by the same body.
The world stood a gasp at the enormity
of the guilt which had resulted from a
rejection of the sacred oracles.
We've talked a lot about oracles, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> And men recognize the necessity of faith
in God and his word as the foundation of
virtue and morality. So we have two
things now Martin.
There is this attempt to get rid of God
out of society. There is this attempt to
deny even his existence. There is
lentiousness that comes into the world.
But God doesn't permit his word to be
taken away. It is there. So you have a
choice.
>> Yeah. And
>> you have a choice between the two. I
think if somebody has a um question if
it really was so, just go back and look
at the news and look at everything that
happened in the past four years.
>> Yes.
>> And up until now, now we'll get to that,
but we already mentioned it. It's being
pushed back.
>> Being pushed back. So what happened in
the French Revolution?
So during the same time period that this
French revolution takes place
and the remnant starts preaching a
message of separation and the three
angels messages.
Satan sets up his counterfeit.
So let's have a look at this in a little
bit more detail. One of the philosophers
of the French Revolution is Voltater.
And these people were anything but
model.
>> But they were also Jesuits.
This is a Jesuit. Now the Jesuits were
created to counter the reformation. What
is the greatest weapon that God gave the
reformation?
>> The Bible.
>> The Bible. So let's attack the Bible.
Otherwise, we can't win this battle,
right?
And let's bring out something in the
place of God's law. And they bring out
this over here which as you can see is a
representation almost of the twin tables
of the law.
>> Yeah,
>> it's just a different law. And if we
look at it in a little bit more detail,
this is the original human rights
declaration of the French Revolution
given in the form of two tables of stone
with a fasci.
So, it's a fascist regime
and it has this funny little hat on the
top there which is the frigian hat, the
Jacabine hat.
>> And we've traced that hat all the way
back to Assyria. Right.
>> Yes.
where the free man,
in other words, modern in modern
terminology, one that is on a level with
Freemasonry,
>> serves a higher power, which is the king
of Assyria, which is the type of the
king of Babylon, which is a type of the
papacy.
>> That's it.
>> Bottom line. And then you have the
Jesuit allseeing eye above it. And of
course, the serpent with a tail in the
mouth. In other words, he's the
lifegiving serpent that doesn't have a
beginning and doesn't have an end. He's
the He is the God of this world,
Lucifer.
So, in the place of God's word, you had
human rights. Human rights. Human
rights. Human rights. Human rights. And
you have the right to everything.
>> Yeah.
>> You even have the right to pornography.
You have the right to satisfy your
lusts. Everything.
So here in the book education who we
read about the French Revolution,
multitudes are thus led to believe that
desire is the highest law.
A license
is liberty and that man is accountable
only to himself. This is the philosophy
with such teaching given at the very
outset of life when impulse is strongest
and the demand for self-restraint and
purity is most urgent. Where are the
safeguards of virtue? What is to prevent
the world from becoming a second Sodom?
At the same time, anarchy because if
there's no law, you have anarchy, right?
is seeking to sweep away all law not
only divine but human. The centralizing
of wealth and power is that taking place
in the world
very much so. I I remember you also
spoke about that in total onslaught how
all the small corporations incorporated
into big conglomerate corporations.
>> Correct. the vast combinations for the
enriching of the few at the expense of
the many.
I mean, how much money did Bezos just
spend on a wedding?
>> Crazy. I can't remember the amount, but
it was
>> They first said a half a billion and
then they said a billion.
>> They could probably have almost bailed
out some countries.
>> They could have bailed out some
countries and and uh a lot of poverty
and hunger could have been alleviated.
The vast combination for the enriching
of the few at the expense of many. The
combination of the poorer classes for
the defense of their interests and
claims. The spirit of unrest of riot and
bloodshed. The worldwide dissemination.
What? What does it say there? There
>> worldwide.
>> Worldwide dissemination of the same
teachings that led to the French
revolution.
all are tending to involve the whole
world in a struggle similar to that
which convulsed France. So we're going
to have a war between mindsets.
>> Well, it's a clash of minds.
>> I must say I think it
this past four years this that came to
fruition.
>> Absolutely. Now who were the movers and
shakers? Well, if you study the French
Revolution, you will see the Jesuits
were behind it. With the flight of the
Hugenos, a general decline settled upon
France. Flourishing
manufacturing cities fell into decay.
Fertile districts returned to their
native wildness. Intellectual dullness.
Moral declenion succeeded a period of
unwanted progress. Paris became one vast
arms house.
And it is estimated that the breaking
out of the revolution 200,000 porpers
claimed charity from the hands of the
king. What? How many people are on
welfare living today? Millions.
The Jesuits
>> alone flourished in the decaying nation
and ruled with dreadful tyranny over
church and schools, the prisons and the
galleys.
The number of young lads and of girls of
17 who were murdered by that excalable
government is to be reckoned by
hundreds. Babies torn from breasts were
tossed from pike to pike along the
jackaban ranks. In the short space of 10
years, multitudes of human beings
perished.
Martin, how much pedophilia is there in
the world today?
>> That's sick. How many
young girls and young boys are
slaughtered in these defiling
situations?
>> Human trafficking.
>> Martin, this spirit is everywhere.
>> And it's always linked to very prominent
and noteworthy people in the media and
all over.
>> Yes. And they go to court and they get
scot-free. Right.
When appearing as members of their
order,
they wore a garb of sanctity, visiting
prisons and hospitals, ministering to
the sick and the poor, professing to
have renounced the world, and bearing
the sacred name of Jesus, talking about
the
>> Jesuits,
>> who went about doing good, but under
this blameless exterior, the most
criminal and deadly purposes were often
concealed. It was a fundamental
principle of the order that the end
justifies the mean. By this code, lying,
theft, perjury, assassination were not
only pardonable but commendable.
When they served the interests of the
church under various disguises, the
Jesuits worked their way into offices of
state, climbing up to be counselors of
kings, shaping the policies of nations.
They became servants to act as spies
upon their masters.
They established as colleges for the
sons of princes and nobles, schools for
the common people and the children of
Protestant parents were drawn into the
observance of popish rights.
>> So all the universities in the world
today are run on Jesuit principles. They
became cesspools modern.
>> God was not allowed to be mentioned.
They had a theology department that had
to strictly stick to their theology,
whatever it was, normally a false
theology, and for the rest, it was
totally secular, godless.
>> Yeah.
>> All the outward pomp and display of the
Roman worship was brought to bear to
confuse the mind and dazzle and
captivate the imagination.
And thus the liberty for which the
fathers had toiled and bled was betrayed
by the sons. The Jesuit rapidly spread
themselves over Europe and wherever they
went they went they followed a revival
of popery.
>> The same
>> and one of the places where they went is
the United States of America where today
the Supreme Court is run by them and the
entire cabinet seems to be under their
sway. Yep.
Notwithstanding the general abhorance
with which it was regarded even in
Catholic countries, this terrible
tribunal
was again set up by the popish rulers.
The atrocities too terrible to bear the
light of day were repeated in its secret
dungeons. In many countries, thousands
upon thousands of the very flower of the
nation and purest and noblest, the most
intellectual and highly educated, pious
and devoted pastors, industrious and
patriotic citizens, brilliant scholars,
talented art artists, skillful artisans
were slain or forced to flee the land.
Such were the means which Rome had
invoked to quench the light of the
reformation. And what did it bring
about, Martin? It brought about the dark
ages.
>> Yeah. And how to to withdraw the Bible
from men.
>> Yeah. And the smallest countries, the
humblest and least powerful nations
became its strongholds. It was little
Geneva in the midst of mighty foes
plotting a destruction. It was Holland
and the sandbanks by the northern sea
wrestling against the tyranny of Spain.
Then the greatest and most opulent of
kingdoms. It was bleak, sterile Sweden
that gained victories for the
reformation. So God kept the reformation
idea alive. But the Jesuits stole the
minds of the people. Now it's
interesting must remember that what this
is the king of the north using his acts
to actually get about the king of the
south.
>> He's sitting at the table.
>> Yes. He's setting it up. the whole king
of the self thing.
>> So the Jacabines were the movers and
shakers of this lentiousness
and this disgusting philosophy.
And when they shall have finished their
testimony, that's now the two witnesses,
the Old and the New Testament. The beast
that ascendeth out of the bottlene piss
shall make war against them and shall
overcome them and kill them.
Literally for three and a half years the
Bible was banned in France. Then it was
unbanned. The great Bible society
started all over the world. But the
governments of the world had become
secularized and God was removed.
>> And a little while later after the Bible
societies they infiltrated that as well.
>> Yes.
And they enthroned a goddess who was a
prostitute
that was called the goddess of reason
and they paraded her through the
streets. Right.
>> Yeah.
>> So the goddess of reason took the place
of the Bible.
So when the goddess this also comes from
the great controversy was brought into
the convention theator took her by the
hand and turning to the assembly said
mortals cease to tremble before the
powerless thunders of a god whom your
fears have created. Disgusting isn't it?
>> It is you see that today with this whole
woke.
>> Exactly. Henceforth acknowledge no
divinity but reason.
I offer you the noblest and purest
image. If you must have idols, sacrifice
only to such as this. Fall before the
august senate of freedom, veil of
reason. So the senate is going to rule
now. The goddess after being embraced by
the president was mounted on a
magnificent car and conducted amidst an
immense crowd to the cathedral of NRAAM
which burnt down lately and had to be
restored to its original splendor.
>> I wonder why.
>> I wonder why. To take the place of the
deity. Then she was elevated on the high
altar and received the adoration of all
present. and Voltater the Jesuit
and all the others that said uh I think
therefore I am all of these Jesuits were
behind this philosophy.
>> Maybe if we look back and we go and look
at exactly when all this really got some
foothold. It will also be three and a
half years ago.
>> Correct. And the power of the kings was
taken away. The countries of the world
became secularized. Even the pope by
Napoleon Freemason was taken captive and
his political entity power taken away
until such time when it should be
restored and we will come to that. So
Martin if we pick up the story in
Revelation chapter 17
you have the beast of revelation chapter
17 and a woman rides upon this beast.
Right now this beast is also the
sevenheaded dragon
but there are no crowns
>> only once.
>> So she's not ruling.
So this is the is not stage as we have
discussed right you had the stage of
papal power where the crowns were on the
horns. She was ruling.
>> Now the crowns are gone. This is this
beast out of the bottomless pit that is
ruling.
And it is a woman that rides the beast
from the bottomless pit. The beast has
no crowns since it is now in the is not
stage but will receive power after this
stage is completed.
>> Okay. So this is the portion where it
still has the seemingly mortal wound.
>> Correct. Now what is the purpose of this
beast not having crowns? In other words,
power to legislate morality according to
their will.
>> So it's just not um able to enforce
their laws. But it's still
>> Yes. So basically, Martin, this is the
stage that is created that has to be
overcome in order to get back to the
ruling stage.
And if we jump down to verse 12, we'll
see that the 10 horns which thou sawest
are 10 kings which have received no
kingdom as yet. They don't have crowns
on them.
But receive power as kings one hour with
the beast. And the beast is always
Catholicism, right?
These have one mind and shall give their
power and strength unto the beast. And
the church is ruling
>> this beast.
So the king of the south philosophy
is a philosophy of atheism
and it's a philosophy of lentiousness.
Do what thou wilt is the whole of the
law. And it is an underground
philosophy. It is a beast that ascends
out of the bottomless pit, puts a new
philosophy into the world, the goddess
of reason, liberty, fraternity, freedom,
brotherhood. We all love each other.
That is the philosophy that is put out
into the world. And in order to
infiltrate,
they do it via the Masonic lodges.
>> So here you have a portrait of Anthony
Sey, the first Grandmaster of the London
Lodge, founded in 1717
to prepare the way for this.
And this is what it looks like. And of
course that is the sign that they have
where they put their hand upon their
chest like this. And then let's have a
look at the title photo of Pas the 12th
of Padelios Patelli's biography and it's
the same symbol. So Rome actually via
the Jesuits creates this system to
infiltrate the political and the
spiritual thinking of the world. And
it's a Luciferian system. It doesn't
acknowledge God, the Bible or his law.
>> Yeah. But that's how they work still
through all of they all have this
proxies. They've got the knights, their
knights of Malta or all the secret
societies doing that infiltration.
>> Correct. So in this time period, what is
developing?
Well, the time period when this beast
out of the bottomless pit rises, we see
the rise of Freemasonry as we've just
seen there.
communism,
spiritualism,
evolutionism which is atheism,
>> theosophy which is Lucifer worship and
existentialism.
So let's just define existentialism.
It is the philosophical belief that we
are each responsible for creating
purpose or meaning in our own lives. Our
individual purpose and meaning is not
given to us by gods, governments,
teachers or other authorities.
>> We decide.
>> Yeah,
>> that is a papal decree. We start with
man. We don't start with God.
>> That's what the Vatican Council said.
We've discussed that many, many times.
So here you have all of these godless
structures.
At the same time you have uh KL Marx
starting the League of Communists and
the Communist Manifesto was written in
published in 1848.
And what was the philosophy?
KL Marx and Frederick Engles met in
Paris and they started a lifelong
association that would change the world.
Two months later, November 1844,
Engles wrote to Markx. This is the
philosophy that we need. We are at
present holding public meetings all over
the place to set up societies for the
advancement of the workers. By a huge
majority, everything Christian was
banned from the rules.
There must be no
God of the Bible involved.
Markx had already written an atheist
handbook titled the assess essence of
Christianity in which he argued against
the existence of God. Is this king of
the south philosophy
>> 100% fits right in
>> right denies the existence of God. Who
is the Lord that I should obey his
voice? I know not Jehovah. I don't care
for him. Is this what he's saying?
>> Yeah.
In 1844 he claimed in one of his works
that the criticism of religion is the
preerequisite of all criticisms.
It was also in this work that he called
religion the opiate of the people. Other
words a drug
>> and in the next sentence proposed the
abolition of religion. Let's get rid of
religion. Yeah.
>> Was that written into the constitution?
Mhm.
>> Didn't the French send the statue of
liberty?
>> Yes. Because it's because of this
wonderful liberty actually of religion.
>> Liberty from what? Modern from God and
the law. Right.
>> As essential for real happiness. And
thus was born Marxism,
socialism and communism
which has brought so much happiness in
the world. I
>> All right, Martin. So, interestingly
enough,
Marxism, socialism, and communism is
that king of the south philosophy.
>> Yes, it fits right into that.
>> It fits right into that. All right. At
the time of the end, the king of the
north,
>> Mhm.
>> which is the papal philosophy
of his law and his rulership will push
against the secular
>> mindset. Who created the secular
mindset?
>> They did.
>> He did
>> through their proxies, the Jesuits.
Right.
>> Adam Vice was a Jesuit and he created
the Illuminati. Right.
>> You said that um it pushed against but
actually the king of the south was
pushing against the king of the north.
So
>> the king of the south was pushing
against him and then he overran him.
>> Yes. So this the when communism and
socialism and all of this got on the
bandwagon like we've seen through the
years, it's been pushing against the
king of the north. But like you just
mentioned, it was created by the same
king of the north. In any case,
>> all right, let's go. Let's get very
practical. Under the Biden
administration, what mindset was ruling?
King of the south or king of the north?
>> King of the South.
>> King of the South philosophy, right?
Lentiousness. Do what you want. uh woke,
you name it. All of those things. We'll
see that in a moment.
>> Yeah.
>> And of course, it was introduced there
also by the Jesuits.
>> Yes.
>> Because the hippie movement
>> with the free love and the drugs that
was
furthered by the Jesuits.
>> Yeah. They went ahead with their little
combi cars full of flowers, passing out
the LSD and the drugs and making sure
that uh we are coming to San Francisco
with flowers in our hair to have a
little bit of lentiousness going on
while we puff and huff
>> sail along silver
bird etc etc. Lucy in the sky with
diamonds. LSD.
>> Yeah. Now, interesting. I was just
thinking Biden is a Catholic, so he's
king of the north, but he lets all of
this happen.
>> He's playing the role of the king of the
south.
>> During the hippie movement, wasn't it
also a king of the north papacy um
candidate for president?
>> Yes. So every time when this push comes
there's actually a a king of the
>> north someone is really ruling he's just
setting up a system right 1844 Martin we
have the origin of species when was this
written by Darin well he drew some short
notes which are enlarged in 1844
so here comes the philosophy of god does
not exist is this king of the south or
King of the north.
>> King of the south.
>> So let's have a look at the concept of a
rise of western lentiousness. Wasn't
that the other criterium for Sodom?
Spiritually Sodom.
>> And if you look it up on the web, this
is what you will find. Just type in rise
of western lentiousness.
I'm quoting directly from
Uncle Google.
Or is it Auntie Google? I don't know.
>> Can be Dr. Google, Professor Google, I
don't know.
>> Whoever. All right.
Reflects a historical and ongoing debate
about morality, social norms, and the
perceived decline of traditional values
in western societies.
It often involves concerns about sexual
freedom, challenging established
hierarchies, a perceived breakdown of
the social order. This perceived rise is
often linked to a broader cultural
shift, including changing attitudes
towards sexuality,
gender, and authority.
Here's a more detailed look at the
concept, historical concept. The term
lensiousness has been used throughout
history to criticize behaviors deemed
immoral or excessive, particularly in
relation to sexual conduct. We just read
that word in the spirit of prophecy,
right?
>> In the 18th and 19th century, isn't that
the time of the French Revolution?
Concerns about lentiousness were often
tied to anxieties about social mobility
and the perceived influence of
unprincipled individuals in politics.
>> More recently, the concept has been
associated with the rise of pornography,
the sexual revolution, other cultural
shifts that challenged
uh traditional sexual morality.
So the key themes are sexual freedom. A
core element of the debate is the
tension between traditional views on
sexual morality and the increased
acceptance of diverse sexual
expressions.
It challenges authority. The concept of
lentiousness can be used to criticize
those who question or undermine the
established social, political and
religious authorities. Martin, do we
have a clash here between two mindsets?
>> Oh, it's like the east is from the west,
the two mindsets.
>> And it's and it's north south, right?
>> Yeah.
>> North is the papal morality.
>> South is this uh freedom, this
godlessness.
>> You take any university, you will be
bombarded with atheism and evolutionism.
No matter what subject you study,
uh when you go to the movie world, it's
Jesuit theater. It's lentiousness. It's
do what thou wilt. You climb into bed
with whoever you want to. It doesn't
matter whether it's male, female. In
fact, it doesn't even matter if it's not
a human.
>> Yeah. in this time that we are living
in. And it is the classic move to bring
about a system where Rome again achieves
authority because Protestantism
and soloscript
have been so watered down that they
cannot even give a squawk
>> yes
>> of resistance. So they join the king of
the north.
>> The king of the north because obviously
he seems to have the clout and the moral
position to dictate a false morality.
>> They've totally forgotten what the
reformers taught about Rome. Now they
join Rome against this secular king of
the south
>> and the social order. Concerns about
lentiousness often reflect anxieties
about the stability of social structures
and the potential of chaos or disorder.
Isn't this anarchy?
>> Ordo,
>> do we have it?
>> Yes.
>> So, let's look at the Trump
administration. Is it fighting against
this?
>> Yeah.
>> Is it using the economy?
>> Yes. Tariffs.
>> Tariffs. removing uh funding funding to
universities. Any one that propagates
wokeness or
>> or women's or transgenders and women's
sport,
>> the defunded.
>> Yeah. Even Doge how they highlighted
some of the misspending, how it went to
making mice trans transgender and all of
these things.
>> Correct. So, there is a massive war. Is
he employing even the military against
any form of uh resistance?
>> Yes.
>> So Martin, the king of the north
philosophy is now destroying the
lentious godless philosophy,
but it's the king of the north doing so.
So this is what is happening on that
scale. And at the same time, the king of
the north is busy setting up his unity
of all religions. Yes,
>> fraternity,
>> Abrahamic Accords, you name it.
>> And therefore, you need cultural change.
The concept is frequently invoked in
discussions about broader cultural
shifts such as the rise of
individualism. Mustn't you get rid of
that? The pope said that
>> yes,
>> you can't be an individualist. You must
be a follower.
>> That's the Jesuit motto. You must It's
for the common good.
>> Consumerism.
Isn't that part of rum Novarum? And
doesn't the modern pope,
Pope Leo,
>> doesn't he propagate that? And
secularism,
>> modern, the king of the south, according
to Revelation 11, according to the
interpretation
that we find in the great controversy
is godlessness and lentiousness. Here we
have it.
>> Yeah. Is there a war against it to
eradicate it and establish again the
king of the north mindset?
>> Yes.
>> And what about the biblical mindset?
Isn't that sidelined then?
>> It's of course
>> so perspectives moral conservatives
often view the rise of lentiousness
as a decline from traditional values and
a threat to the social order. Do we find
that today? Yes, we see that in with the
Trump administration trying to get rid
of all this uh social order and all of
this.
>> At the time of the end, the king of the
south will push against the king of the
north. He got rid of his political
clout.
He went underground. Got rid of faith in
God, faith in the Bible, faith in God as
the creator. brought in lensiousness,
free love, wokeness, you name it. And
now the reverse must take place having
gotten rid of Protestantism and
swallowed it up in the ecommenical
movement.
>> So social liberals may argue that
concerns about lentiousness are often
exaggerated. Isn't that what we find in
the media?
>> Exactly. You know, we we said all of
this. We said the pendulum will swing so
far that it will swing back and now it's
being swinging back and people are still
now trying to look somewhere else.
>> All right. So what is the swing? It was
king of the north then it became king of
the south. The king of the south became
very uppety under particularly under the
Biden administration and all over
Europe. I mean look at London. It is a
sex pool
>> the world
>> and the world or go into some of the
streets of Berlin or any one of those
cities in Paris or whatever and see what
it's like and now the pendulum has to
swing back
and that greater sexual freedom and
social tolerance are positive
developments that mindset has to go. So
that's a summary from Google. So what
are the examples that we have?
Pornography. The rise of pornography in
the 20th and 21st century has been a
major focus of concern about
lentiousness with critics arguing it
promotes sexual exploitation harms
individuals and society. Always society
is involved.
Social movements advocating the LGBT
rights, reproductive rights, other
social changes have been accused of
promoting lentiousness by challening
traditional norms. Traditional norms.
Who who hammers on tradition?
>> The Catholic Church, Roman Catholic
Church.
>> Political discourse. The term
lentiousness can be used in political
rhetoric to attack opponents and
demonize their ideas. Is that happening
today? You see, it it happened quite a
bit under the Biden administration. Now
it's being overrun.
>> Aha. And they're backtracking. Yeah.
>> Because they're afraid of the economy.
>> I mean,
>> the money being taken away.
>> That uh the University of Pennsylvania
Yes.
>> had to change. They had to to take back
the rewards that was handed out to these
people.
>> Yes. And under one pretext or another,
you're going to be arrested and you're
going to be put away if you don't play
ball. So in conclusion can we say that
the idea of a rise of western
lentiousness is a complex and contested
concept. It reflects ongoing debates
about morality, chastal change and the
tension between individual freedom and
social order. Uh common good is that
social order?
>> Definitely.
>> And what will be the end of all of this?
Well, Revelation ends the story after
having brought in this king of the south
philosophy that now has to be overrun
and the kings of the world must give
their power back to the beast. In other
words, Rome will again dictate its
morality by law.
>> And then what happens?
Verse 15 in chapter 11. And the seventh
angel sounded, and there was great
voices in heaven, saying, "The kingdoms
of this world are become the kingdoms of
our Lord and of his Christ, and he shall
reign forever and ever."
>> The kingdom of God will be set up, not
by man. We've discussed that.
And the four and 20 elders which sat
before God on their seats fell upon
their faces and worshiped God, saying,
We give thee thanks, O Lord God
Almighty, which art and was and are to
come because thou has taken to thee thy
great power and has reigned. No earthly
power is going to reign. No. And the
nations were angry, and thy wroth is
come, and the time of the dead, that
they should be judged, and that thou
should give reward unto thy servants,
the prophets, and to the saints, and
them that fear thy name, small and
great, and should destroy them which
destroy the earth.
So, Martin, God is going to destroy the
whole system.
And the temple of God was opened in
heaven, and there was seen in the temple
the ark of the testament. That's the law
of God.
And there were lightnings and voices and
thunders and earthquakes and a great
hail. So is the law of God going to be
pivotal? Center.
>> And then there is the earthquake and the
great hail. That's the seventh plague,
the destruction of everything.
>> So basically we can sum up by saying
thy word is a lamp unto my feet and a
light unto my path. Either we stick to
that or we end up with papal power which
negates the word of God and sets up its
own set of morality.
>> And if we don't stick to this
>> then we'll end up in Egypt which is
>> king of the south philosophy
>> and the king of the north philosophy is
going to prevail.
>> It's going to take over. It's setting up
its situations and Turkey has absolutely
nothing to do with it.
>> It will be incorporated in the
>> correct. It's already cooperated in the
king of the north. Let's end with a
final quote.
In the words of an early reformer
concerning the Christian church, the
Bible is an anvil
that has worn out many hammers. It Yeah.
It will wear out the hammer of the king
of the south and it will wear out the
hammer of the king of the north. Both
are going to be destroyed by the word of
God,
says the Lord. No weapon that is formed
against thee shall prosper, and every
tongue that shall rise against thee in
judgment, thou shalt condemn.
The word of God is going to be the
winner.
The word of our God shall stand forever.
All his commandments are sure. They
stand fast forever and ever and are done
in truth and uprightness.
Isaiah 40:8, Psalms 111. You might as
well read Psalms 119 as well. The whole
thing,
>> whatever is built upon the authority of
man
will be overthrown. But that which is a
founded upon the rock of God, immutable
word shall stand forever. Martin, if we
don't take our stand on this book.
If we don't keep the commandments of God
as they are written in this book,
we will be overthrown.
Any government or any religious system
that alters or changes the words in this
word in this book will receive the
plagues that are promised in this book.
So the king of the south, it's
secularism,
its atheism, its lentiousness.
That philosophy must give way to the
king of the north philosophy, papal
supremacy, papal fables, papal laws,
and all nations will give their power
unto the beast, including the Islamic
ones.
That is the story of the Bible. I don't
read any other story and that is the war
that we have to watch and nothing else.
>> Amen.
>> Let's pray.
>> Heavenly Father,
your word is very clear as to who the
enemy is, who we must watch, and what
the end times events are.
And I pray that you will open the minds
and hearts of your people that they may
understand that the only safety
is the righteousness of Christ, his
kingdom, his law. And this is that I my
prayer that all will make a right
application of the word and understand
it in Jesus' name. Amen. Amen.
Heat.
[Music]